Hi, my name is Lorenzo, and
I'll be your instructor as we
explore the foundations of
full stack web development.
In this course you will learn to build
your own data-driven web application,
but what does that actually mean?
Well, when I say web application
I'm referring to a web page or
collection of pages that allows your
browser to respond to user input,
similar to an offline
software application.
And by data-driven,
I mean an application that can store and
retrieve information from a database to
deliver customized content to the user.
Almost all of the popular websites
you interact with on a daily basis
are data-driven web applications.
Soon you will create a similar
website of your own.
In addition to creating web pages, you
will also learn to send data from your
server in other forms,
like JSON requests.
So that the data from your application
can be shared with other machines that
process JSON, like a data aggregator or
a mobile device.
Your mission in this course is
to help me create a menu app.
You'll be building an interactive
web application that presents a user
a variety of menu items they can view,
create, modify, and delete.
In the first lesson of this course
you will extract data from a database
using Python.
We'll also be using a tool called
an object-relational mapping, or
ORM to manipulate queries
as objects in Python.
If you've never heard of an ORM,
don't worry.
You'll be very familiar with
it in just a few minutes.
In the second lesson you will build
your first data-driven web application
using only the libraries that
come installed with Python.
In the third lesson we will
talk about frameworks and
create an application using
the lightweight web framework, Flask.
You will understand how frameworks help
developers write code more efficiently.
Once you complete this course you
will easily be able to compare and
contrast frameworks, and choose one
of your own for future projects.
Finally, you'll use what you
learned from lessons one, two, and
three to iteratively write code until
you have a polished menu application,
complete with API endpoints for
JSON requests.
Let's get started.